(smooth upbeat jazz tune)
I am standing with the icon of Uptown style,
Dapper Dan. Good to see you sir.
My pleasure, it's such a great joy
to have you come to Harlem.
That's so nice - you've got a -
this handshake's a little crazy. You don't stop!
No, I don't stop. (laughs)
I'm not a well. What, are you tryin'
to get water out of me? What are you doin' there?
Wait, hold up, let me give you part two.
Okay, there's a part two. There we go,
there we go, there we go. Now he has it.
You've been responsible for so many iconic looks,
can you show me some of your looks?
Oh, yeah! Let me show you now.
What's this right here? This is the Fat Boys.
Yeah, that's the Fat Boys.
Okay, incredible.
Eric B. And Rakim.
Okay, You styled them?
Salt-N-Pepa.
That's Salt - you did Salt-N-Pepa!
Yeah, Salt-N-Pepa.
Look at that!
You think I can pull that off,
Dapper Dan? That look?
Uh.
I've got long legs and I'm very feminine
Oh, okay but I - I think we might
have to kill the leggings though.
I like leggings.
You like leggings?
I like the way they hug the body.
(Dan laughs)
I was actually serious, what happened there?
Uh-oh.
This isn't working for me and I'll be honest
with you, this has never worked for me.
Okay, so I'm gonna invite you into
the domain of swag - Harlem swag.
This is what you call, Harlem swag.
This is Harlem swag?
This is Harlem swag.
What would this be called, right here?
Casual.
(audience laughter)
Straight casual.
Yeah, you said it was disdain.
No, it's okay if you... passin' through.
I'm a guy, just...passin' through.
Yeah.
So what we wanna do is, we wanna try
and bump me up a notch. I want the look.
Oh, okay.
I want the Dapper Dan look.
That's what I'm a give you
and we gonna just swag you up and down.
You're gonna swag me up and down.
Swag you all the way up and down.
Okay... sounds a little weird.
(Dan laughs)
You gotta have some swag.
When you walk, you gotta have -
I walk a little, let me show you my walk
and you tell me what you think of it.
(audience laughts)
Keep walking. (laughs)
You don't like that walk?
No, you gotta keep walking with that one.
That's me, I'm late!
This is me late!
Go.
(Conan laughs)
Let me try, I like that! You've got it all -
God, man. You're the best! Look at this!
No, look -
I got that, I got that, look at that!
Yeah, yeah, there you go!
But see, I do too much.
I do too much and it looks like
I haven't had my medicine.
You've got to have the shoulder dip.
Okay.
(audience laughter)
That's fantastic! Dan,
see Dan, when I do that, it looks
like I was just in a car accident. Doesn't it?
(Dan laughs)
I got it all wrong! My Toyota,
just hit the fire hydrant and I -
I'm try to get away before the cops show up.
(Dan laughs)
Because I have no insurance,
that's the look I have.
Yeah, but we gonna have it right.
Dapper Dan, swag me up.
That's right.
Hey Dap?
Yeah?
I found something.
Oh, great, great, great!
Give me your honest opinion.
(audience laughter and applause)
Is this a Pee Wee Herman special
we're getting ready to do, or what?
What do you mean Pee Wee Herman?
This is - look at this, this spoke to me.
I saw this hanging -
No, it didn't spoke to you,
it cursed at you.
(audience laughter)
Who's laughing? You think this is funny?
No, sir. (chuckles)
You're laughing at me.
Remember, we going to Swagville.
Mm-hm.
This is not Swagville.
Does anyone know what neighborhood this is?
Where would I go? Wait..
Soho.
(audience laughter)
I got the moves in this.
The spin is nice.
You like the spin? I got him with the spin!
Look at that, I got the spin.
I believe in the spin.
The spin might work.
Now if you could just keep doing it
so they don't see what's going on.
(audience laughter)
Dap?
Mm-hm?
Give me a minute to try this on my own. Okay?
Okay.
(audience laughs and cheers)
You like plaid? Plaid, plaid, plaid, plaid.
Nah, you look fabulous to me.
(audience laughter)
You come up to New York to be a pimp
or something?
You think I look like a pimp?
Yeah - no, you look like somebody
trying to be a pimp!
Wait, I don't even look like a pimp.
I look like a guy who's trying to be a pimp!
Exactly.
It's called unemployed pimp.
I'm an unemployed pimp.
Yeah.
Thanks for the help. Thank you for -
yeah, okay.
Dap, you ready?
Yeah, I'm ready!
Now, this outfit here...
Listen.
It looks like you were nominated
for five BET Awards and you have five outfits
and you wore them all at the same time.
(audience laughs)
Did I win?
Maybe the jacket's too much. Maybe when I take
off the jacket, you see a see-through shirt.
Look how easily this comes open.
You see that?
(Dan laughs)
(audience hollers)
That's it, that's it!
You like that? You like that? Look at that.
Totally play it. What's the matter? You like it?
It's hot.
(audience laughs)
Okay, you're being a wise-ass.
What says Harlem more than that?
(Dan laughs)
You say this is not an authentic Harlem look?
No. Absolutely not.
I think you're wrong, I would like to
go outside and get a second opinion or two.
Do you mind?
Let's go.
What do you think of my outfit?
I don't like it.
You think you don't like it? It's -
do you think I look attractive in this?
No.
Nah.
Who asked you? Why did you jump in?
I agree, that you probably have the better idea.
So, why don't you swag me up. You do it.
I need to get swagged up by Dap!
Dap style, let's go do it.
(Dan laughs)
Come on! Yeah!
(crowd cheering loudly)
Let's do this!
(audience applauds)
(upbeat jazz music)
We did it!
(audience applauds)
Dapper Dan, ladies and gentleman!
(audience cheers loudly)
This is fantastic!
Let's give it up for my tailor, Barry!
Barry, where are you?
Give it up for Barry right there!
(audience applauds)
Dapper Dan, you're a genius.
Thank you!